for these small businesses competing
against retail Giants one way they can
separate themselves is by engaging with
customers that's the main reason Indra
Turner says she opened her brick and
mortar shop nearly two months ago
located along the southern end of Water
Street in Henderson she says only doing
online sales burned her out I enjoy
meeting the public at especially small
you know Henderson being a small town I
enjoy
being able to interact with my customers
instead of just texting all day on the
internet Turner High sold jewels and Gem
crystals for around eight years she
relies on the support of a steady
clientele while you're making our dreams
come true really I mean I'm able to do
something that I love further north on
Water Street is Archer and Jane Crystal
Moses began the business nearly eight
years ago selling second hand in new
children clothing the store was born out
of frustration she had buying things off
of Craigslist and Facebook Marketplace
you can travel pretty far for stuff
that's just not in good condition or not
as described and I thought we need a
place like this in our community where
you can trust the items are quality
items and you're going to get a good
price over at Container Park small
businesses also took part in shop local
Saturday they tend to benefit from
tourists visiting the Fremont Street
Experience I feel like when you buy
local you support your local economy you
know I mean first off the second thing
is you support someone's dream you know
I mean it's a one-of-a-kind business
that you know I mean you can't find
anywhere else small businesses say it's
important cities and Patriots support
their shops because most of their funds
go right back into the community Joshua
peguero eight news now